có bố cảnh thằng thiết tục theo thằng tại Trung Đông.
Thì Strand một lần nữa khẳng định sức mạnh không quanh
với chiến tấu cơ em về làm thì ra âm
khi bạn cả đến tập biệt tương em về làm es,
phải ý hồ của biệt.
Chắc bị tâm cơ em một khâu không về W 2,
với lần đây, sự tạc lên tối 1,2% khi lo điều tân.
Em về làm ý có khả năng tạp tất hoát hai chăm lắm.
Tâm biệt, 3,4%
Được tính giá là một trong những kếp tích ra nghiệp mạnh nhất khu vật.
Rà em, lần như tự hào của khâu quên Thì Strand.
Bối tâm hạt lâu có phó phía chi trọng kí lo mét
và trởi tự hỏi tối mùi tâm kí lo mét
Rà em có thể tấn công các buộc biểu sâu trong lạnh thuộc bất cơm
mạnh không cần thiết biệt liều.
Dâu kình em về làm ý tực sự tạng gầm
chính là khả năng mạnh theo của bùi năng tấn bú khi
bự tên giợ không bối thông, không bối đất
tối bòn sức đường thu mình và cả bảo sấu nằm em xóu bộ hà hai.
Được chăng bị ra ra à nờ APG, mạnh không ý
và hệ thống quan sát làm thiền em về làm ý
có thể hợp chiến sát ngay cả trong việc hợp giữa hợp giữa sấu và điện hình tức tạng.
Đây là buổi khi Thèn Chốt trong các chiến dịch không biết chiến sát của Istraain.
Độ nỗ vì công đường vũ nhận đặc biệt
kết hợp với công nghệ giữa tạng giúp em về làm ý
chợp hàng lực lượng sát đẹp chiến lượng không chỉ ở trúc đông
mặt còn trên trường bú tế.